- [Voiceover] Alright, grammarians.
So we know that there's one way
to use this thing we
call reflexive pronouns
and that's to say you're
doing something to yourself,
as in the sentence
I made myself breakfast.
Right, I'm making myself breakfast.
Or in the sentence
Ronaldo cut himself shaving.
Sorry about the capital S
there, that is a mistake.
So Ronaldo and himself and I and myself.
We use, these are called
reflexive pronouns
and we use them when the subject
and the object of a sentence
is the same thing, right,
but there's another way to
use these reflexive pronouns
and it's called emphatic usage.
So I want you to imagine
me storming off in a huff
or getting really excited
as I say the following:
Well, if you won't help
me, I'll do it myself!
Or, he's lying, I heard it myself.
Or, the princess herself is
running the charity marathon.
And what this is is what we
call emphatic or intensive
because we use it to intensify a statement
or to grant it emphasis, right?
This is how it works.
So instead of just saying...
and the difference, the key
difference, between reflexive
and intensive or emphatic
usage of this kind of pronoun
is you could take these
right out of a sentence
and it would still make sense.
I'll do it, I heard it, the
princess will run the marathon.
Right, we're using them as intensifiers
which really means
they can come right out.
They're not essential to the
understanding of the sentence,
you're just using these words
in order to hammer home a point.
You know, if someone
else isn't helping you
you say I'll do it, but you wanna really
hammer home the fact
that you're going to be
doing it alone so you say
I'll do it myself.
And if you wanna emphasize
that you were there
and you heard something
happen you would say
I heard it myself.
And if it's really crazy that
the princess is running this
marathon then you would say
whoa, the princess herself
will be there, and that's nuts.
And that's the intensive
or emphatic pronoun.
That's how you use it.
You can learn anything.
David out.